i thought the best way to reveal my
decision about continuing on
after 44 years or not continuing on
would be to go to marianne from brooklyn
and why maryam from brooklyn i just feel
maryam from brooklyn has been a loyal
fan
she's very concerned about whether i'm
signing or not what i delivered to
marianne's house
is a safe there's two sites really
yes they're in a box and the box will
contain my answer
about whether i'm staying or leaving and
i thought this would be a dramatic way
to either say goodbye or to say hello to
another couple of years
oh boy if you open the box marianne
oh my god howard i'm opening the box
i can't
this will now tell you whether i'm
staying or leaving after many
probably a whole year
[Music]
don't open those boxes yet do you see
the one with the
red ribbon on it when you open up the
package
marianne yeah
you'll find a safe in there oh my god
howard you got to be kidding me i don't
know how to use the stage
[Music]
inside that pink safe is the answer
as to whether i'm staying or leaving i'm
going to give you clues so you can
figure out the combination
to the safe oh dear oh boy
if you enter the wrong combination it
will detonate and you will blow your
whole house
and yourself included well marianne this
could be the interview
[Music]
there are four digits to open the safe
the first two digits are ronnie's
favorite number 69 right so
put in six nine six nine
69 and now if you get the next two
numbers right you'll open that up and
you'll read to everyone what my decision
is about staying or leaving
oh my god the second two numbers
are the amount of years robin and i have
been broadcasting together on the air
33 no 39
try it oh my god
i did 39. all right open it
it's not opening maybe
oh you opened it oh great okay
okay okay wait wait how does it open
tell me the hell is going on she won't
be able to open the door
[Music]
once you open it read to us whether i am
staying or leaving
the rating you can't open it i can't get
it open
we have four hours oh my god i'm sorry
is she turning the knob
can i call my husband he's very good at
it
oh just twist the knob
okay there's an envelope inside holy
[ __ ]
oh my goodness
and what does it say mary and nobody
knows
[Music]
that's right marianne i'm staying on the
radio
i've signed a five-year deal
with um serious satellite radio i'll
stay for another five years
five years for how long howard five
five years for how long
[Music]
what does that
[Music]
thank you mary that's funny wow